بكل المقاييس كان
حادثًا مخيفًا وخطيرًا للغاية تورط فيه
الأمير البريطاني هاري وزوجته ميغان ووالدة
ميغان، دوريا راجلاند،
يقول المتحدث باسم هاري إنهم كانوا في
مطاردة سيارة شبه كارثية في مدينة نيويورك
شارك فيها مصورون عدوانيون
استمرت لمدة ساعتين من إنفاذ القانون
يقول المصدر إنه كان هناك العديد من
المكالمات القريبة ولكن لم يكن هناك حادث سيارة فعلي، حيث
كان الزوجان يحضران حفل توزيع الجوائز
ليلة الثلاثاء حيث تم
تكريم ميغان، وهذه هي الصور التي
ترونها الآن لهاري وميغان وهما يغادران
هذا الحدث، حسنًا، دعنا نحضر
ماكس مراسل CNN الملكي  فوستر بالنسبة لنا، لذا
أخبرنا ماكس بالتفاصيل الجديدة التي
تتعلمها وما الذي حدث بالفعل
ليلة الثلاثاء ومدى اقتراب الأمر من
الكارثة لأننا سمعنا أن
مطاردة السيارة هذه كان من الممكن أن تكون قاتلة
أم نعم، لذلك عندما يتحدثون عنها
قاتل إنهم يتحدثون عن
حقيقة وجود عدة
مركبات أه سيارات حجب الضوء عن السيارات ولكن
أيضًا دراجات ودراجات نارية تطاردهم
من الحدث الذي كانت فيه ميغان
الليلة الماضية حيث حصلت على جائزة
استمرت لمدة ساعتين تقريبًا وكان عليهم المبادلة
السيارات كان عليهم أن يمروا بالعديد من
المواقف المختلفة الخطيرة وفي
نقاط معينة كان هناك أشخاص يعبرون
الطريق وكان هناك أشخاص على
الأرصفة أيضًا وبدوا وكأنهم
في خطر وكان من الممكن أن
يُقتلوا بسبب العملية هنا لذا  لقد
تجاوزوا الأضواء الحمراء، على سبيل المثال،
كانوا يعترضون طريق سيارة الليموزين التي
كانت تستقلها ميغان وهاري ودوريا راجلاند،
وقالوا إن الأمر كان
صادمًا للغاية، وكان هناك الكثير من
الانتهاكات على طول الطريق، وهم
يقولون بشكل أساسي إن الأمر كان
صادمًا للغاية  وقد شعروا
بالارتياح الشديد لعودتهم ولم يكن هناك
حادث تحطم ولكنه كان موقفًا خطيرًا للغاية ولقد
تحدثت
للتو مع رئيس التفاصيل الأمنية الخاصة بهم
والذي وصف كيف كانوا
يحاولون البقاء ضمن القانون  ولهذا
السبب استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً
للتفاوض بشأن هذه الشوارع، لكن كان الأمر
صعبًا للغاية عندما كان كل شيء فوضويًا للغاية
من حولهم، لذلك
حدثت لحظة مؤلمة للغاية في منتصف الليل تقريبًا في
الساعات الأولى من الصباح،
لذلك حصلنا على هذا البيان الطويل من
لقد قيل لنا أنه لم يتواصل أي من أفراد
العائلة المالكة معهم
بعد، ولم نسمع أي شيء من
قصر باكنغهام أو قصر كنسينغتون في لندن
حول هذا الأمر، لذلك نحن ننتظر الحصول على
ردود في كل مكان ولكن من الواضح أنها
لحظة مؤلمة للغاية ومن الواضح
يتحدث عن نشأة هاري حيث أصيب
بصدمة نفسية بسبب الطريقة التي ماتت بها والدته
وطاردها المصورون في باريس وكان
لديه دائمًا غطاء يحمي ميغان من
مصير مماثل، فهو يخشى أن
تعاني بطريقة مماثلة ولهذا
السبب انتقلوا إلى أمريكا،
نعم، صدمة عميقة للغاية  بالنسبة
له، نظرًا لطبيعة مطاردة
المصورين لوالدته وكيف
ماتت، أعني ماكس بالنسبة لك، فقد انتقلوا
إلى الولايات المتحدة إلى لوس أنجلوس لتجنب هذا
النوع من انتهاك الخصوصية، ونحن نعلم
أن هاري نفسه متورط بالفعل
في هذا الأمر  القضايا القانونية هنا في المملكة المتحدة حول
هذه القضية بالضبط